[Music]
the other one which I found even more
fascinating is for achieving some level
of inner peace and I'll give you an exam
is for the first few years it's been a
long time since I thought about it well
let's start with it going to sleep
example if those quick tricks don't work
for you this kind of approach gives you
the sort of bigger gun approach will
give you a sense of what I mean by
taking control of your brain so if those
tricks don't work here's what you do
you personify each of the thought
patterns that are racing through your
head and here's what I mean you have
something about family that you are
stewing about so that's mr. family you
have something about finances Oh should
I made this investment or should I have
not made this investment or I'm running
low and this in my bank account or what
am I going to do about this check that's
coming up or is it something about work
oh my boss said this to me today let's
do about that for 49 minutes you know or
you know my significant other said that
is he or she really thinking this or
really think let's do about that for
another 57 minutes and replay that video
day for 57 minutes or my parents this or
my kids that let's worry about that
problem then cycle back to the finances
and cycle back and you give each of them
a character give each of them a
character whatever you want to name them
now you put them around a table and you
are the chairman of that board and you
say you start by assuming positive
intent the character that's steering
about the work you thank them for their
thoughts and you say thank you for
raising those things because that may be
helping me and you may be playing that
videotape because you want me to learn a
lesson so let's talk about and Ben
before I start how many minutes do you
think you need I hear you but the reason
you're replaying this video in my head
is that something happened today and
you're replaying that video and over
there's a very good reason that you're
doing that and I appreciate that because
you're watching out for me you want me
to learn the lesson from that
yep so let's do this this is the inner
conversation you have with that one
character and then you're gonna repeat
how many minutes do you need to explain
the lesson this is do you think you need
30 minutes well not really 30 how about
one well one is not enough so then you
end up with like let's take two minutes
and we're just gonna listen to it you
analyze the vania so here's what you're
trying to tell me it's this lesson I
said this stupid thing to my boss
I really shouldn't do that in this
situation here's what I should do and
then you ask that engineer or that
character who's playing that video work
video over and over and over where you
said some dumb thing did I get the
lesson right yes is that good
yes do you want to keep going or was
that enough for tonight do you think we
should get some rest now we're done boom
sits down then you go to the next the
one that's doing about what you happened
with your significant other or spouse or
whatever lets you and you're playing
some stupid video of some stupid thing
that you did and shouldn't have done
let's go through that how many minutes
do you need you converge and agree and
you go how many minutes you give that
character your full attention you think
and you start by thanking it for
watching out for you assume positive
intent instead of making enemies with
your thoughts and trying to suppress
them you become partners with them
friends with them and now you walk
through one by one each of the three or
four or five characters that were
playing videos or or sounds or audio
about stuff that happened that day that
you are stewing about and you just walk
around the table and as soon as you're
done as soon as the last person says
okay I'm done you feel this like
incredible calm and then you just go to
sleep
you